our voicemail number is 2192 David P
here is a great voicemail from someone
who appreciates all of the debate
coverage that we have been doing this
election season
sir this is Caitlin from Florida thank
you I just wanted to call to thank you
for your coverage of all of these
debates I've really been enjoying your
coverage I missed the DeSantis Chris
debate last night so I went to the gym
and started your live stream to listen
to this morning and I was
delighted to be surprised by your new
David pakman and Mike pillow remix so
there I was lifting weights to the sound
of that song well that is that is an
absolutely heartwarming thing to hear
two things on this one
we have streamed probably a dozen
different debates so far this election
season one of the most interesting ones
is tonight Mehmet Oz versus John
fetterman I hope you will join me at 7
30 p.m Eastern on YouTube twitch and
Facebook and secondly yes Chris Barrios
putting together one of the best remixes
ever of anything we have done listen to
just a little bit of this masterpiece
worried about my espresso machine
it's not a joke I'm worried about my
Lane
you're like
um
[Music]
okay you get the point anyway remixes
debates all of it join me tonight at 7
30 p.m Eastern Oz versus fetterman we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about the new British prime
minister Rishi sunak we will talk about
Mark Hamill by the way a fan of the
David packman show
fan of the David background Mark Hamill
sending 500 drones to Ukraine and we
will talk about Adidas or as some call
it Adidas cutting ties with Kanye West
after the anti-Semitism explosion all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com